il ya quelques mois je vous avait emmené
avec moi à new york pour découvrir le
nouveau plaque type de google c'est le
google pixels 4 et là vient d'arriver en
milieu d'année le google pixels 4 à
regarder là juste là c'est écrit noir
sur blanc ce smartphone là et ce
smartphone là il fait très jolies
promesses et il est vachement
intéressante pour plusieurs choses
alors je vais tous vous détailler tout
vous expliquer parce que c'est un
smartphone qui pourrait potentiellement
vous intéresser si vous cherchez un
smartphone un peu compact mais avant
toute chose si ce n'est pas déjà fait
vous invite à venir vous abonner
pourquoi pas parce que je vous parle
bien évidemment de nouveautés smartphone
phare le plein d'actus nous parle de
teck
en règle générale ils vous parlent tous
de vous de votre vie numérique je donne
plein de bons conseils plein bonne
astuce que j'aime partager directement
avec vous ici sur cette chaîne j'avais
donc à lire cliquez sur petit la pki
bouton petit bouton rouge que vous avez
là si les rouges c'est vous les bleus
toujours pas cliqué vous cliquez dessus
vous abonnez vous actionnez la cloche
comme ça vous serez notifié vous saurez
tout dès qu une prochaine vidéo arrivera
pour faire simple le pixel 4 ha ça
pourrait potentiellement être
l'équivalent de l'iphone et ce sur
android alors je dis potentiellement
parce que c'est pas exactement ça on
n'est pas dans la même idée notamment en
terme de puissance sur l'iphone est ce
de 2020 vous avez exactement le même sac
que l'iphone 11 pro ici c'est pas le cas
alors il ya quelques différences
notables mais ce qui est sûr c'est que
le format avec un écran de 5,8 pouces
les rapproche énormément et le fait
d'avoir un seul capteur qui fait tout à
l'arrière et le dogue un petit peu la
même adn le pix à 4 ha c'est avant tout
un petit format un smartphone très
compact garder se tient très très bien
dans une main on est vraiment dans cette
typologie de petit écran ont lavé avec
le pixel 4 on retrouve avec le pixel 4 à
un smartphone qui néanmoins a débord qui
sont pas très grand ça reste très
cohérent pouvoir connaît sur un
smartphone milieu de gamme en écran
poids sonné pour voir qu'on a un de
plastique je trouve que les faits plutôt
bien réussi 143 g je trouve vraiment pas
particulièrement lourd il est compact la
prise en main est bonne on à l'avant en
verre corning gorilla glass 3 c'est pas
la dernière génération mais ça
fonctionnera bien sûr ce smartphone là
et surtout ce qui est bien c'est un
écran ici de
8 pouces est due aux led full hd plus de
1340 par 1080 pixels à 443 pixels par
pouce c'est un ratio 19,5 ne vienne
l'écran est vraiment de très très très
bonne qualité pour tous qui va être
contenu multimédia il est extrêmement
bien calibrée personnellement je trouve
vraiment très très bon pour le
multimédia grâce à son écran ça ira très
bien alors après on est sur du 5,8
pouces s'est pas non plus qu'il est le
plus grand si vous voulez un bon confort
de visionnage avec un écran un peu plus
grand c'est ce que vous recherchez
c'est pas forcément la tuque il faudrait
aller peut-être passer votre chemin mais
si par contre vous les quelque chose de
compact avec un excellent rapport
qualité prix
là par contre un truc qui est vraiment
top la puce ya un point qui est vraiment
intéressant et qu'on retrouve en règle
générale assez peu dans cette gamme de
prix parce qu'elle coûte tout de suite
tout est écrit la leçon ma petite note à
349 euros
il est pas cher vraiment pas cher on a
des haut parleurs stéréos qui vient
porter un peu plus en immersion et dans
cette gamme de prix c'est très bien
alors il ya effectivement des haut
parleurs stéréo mais vous avez également
et ça c'est cool
une petite prise jack le son est
vraiment de bonne qualité et si vous
avez un casque bluetooth vous pouvez le
connecter grâce au bluetooth cinq points
vous avez plein de codecs acea ptx à
péter x hdl des ac et sa smart phones
qu'il faut penser à venir protéger parce
que même si vous avez un petit deux
places est très sympathique et bien
c'est mieux de le protéger pour éviter
de venir la bible rien et pour ça vous
avez les coques de mon partenaire et nos
chiffres c'est l'instant sponsorisés sur
la vidéo coque très sympa alors vous
avez la possibilité en plusieurs
couleurs regardez là ça c'est une solide
sud et fait un peu carbone que le doigt
les plastiques regardez là ça c'est très
très cool vous le mettez vous venez de
protégez vous avez un smartphone qui est
très jolie les gaz est toujours accès
très très facilement quand on emprunte
digitale qui déverrouille en plus
extrêmement rapidement ça c'est sympa
donc à sept premiers points et j'aime
beaucoup est le deuxième ça va être une
autre solide suite qui celle-là et colle
tellement un peu plus classique et voyez
un peu plus lire un peu plus passe
partout mais toutefois aussi très
élégante
vous retrouvez bien évidemment le petit
emplacement pour votre prise jack qui
est là pour votre doigt pour
déverrouiller enfin y'a un truc qui
marche bien et qui est très sympa si
vous êtes intéressé vous a mis un petit
code promo embâcles donnera une remise
spéciale manque le petit kangourou c'est
très cool tout ça est en bas dans la
description meert et qui meurt sig
remercié rhinochill ça c'est cool
rappaz 26 le processeur plus performant
on a un stand dragonne 730g on est très
clairement dans l'idée du milieu de
gamme ils nous ont couplé à sacy giga de
ram et 128 go de stockage non extensible
si giga de ram c'est aux intéressés la
lp derrière 4x ça fonctionne très bien
et ça apporte de la fluidité
vous avez aucun ralentissement lorsque
vous allez venir joueurs vous allez
venir naviguer lorsque vous allez venir
scrollé on va pas aller aussi loin que
ce que vous allez avoir effectivement
avec le pixel 4 ou avec d'autres
smartphones plus haut de gamme dans
cette année 2020 mais une fois de plus
on est à 349 euros
on va pas lui demander la lune on retour
d'expérience pur si vous voulez jouer à
des jeux si vous voulez naviguer aller
sur vos réseaux sociaux
faire des photos vous avez suffisamment
de performance et de ce point de vue là
vous serez pas déçus maintenant il ya un
point sur lequel le pixel 4 ha est moins
bon que la concurrence et c'est très
souvent le cas sur les pixels c'est
l'autonomie
vous avez une batterie de 3140
milliampères heures ok vous avez de la
recharge rapide rapide 18 watts
ok ça c'est vrai elop d'autres
smartphones vont tenir un jour et demi
de jour est bien avec le pixel 4 à 6
voutey la journée vous êtes contents
alors vous tenez la journée oui
normalement vous tenez la journée ça
dépend une fois de plus de vous de vos
usages si vous avez un usage intensif
oui ou non mais il va lui manquer ce
petit quelque chose qui va lui conférer
plus d'autonomie et qui vous emmène au
bout de la journée sans aucune
déconvenue vous pouvez y arriver
vous pouvez le faire c'est sûr mais il
va falloir un visage un petit peu modéré
sur un usage intensif mais on peut y
arriver
c'est le problème des pixels 1 de toute
façon sont des super smartphone mais
l'autonomie toujours un petit peu ce
qu'ils vont retourner sur l'android dit
de l'android pur vous avez toutes vos
apps ça marche bien c'est très très très
très pratique alors effectivement il
faut aimer google moi personnellement je
trouve ça vraiment bien j'aimais déjà
sur pixels 4
j'aime également sur le pixel 4 1 et en
plus vous avez trois ans de mise à jour
de sécurité garantie donc ça c'est bien
concernant la partie photo danse un
capteur de 12,2 mégapixels qui ouvre à f
un point cette stabilisation optique et
électronique
il vous pouvez faire de la vidéo
jusqu'en 4k à 30 fps tandis qu'à l'avant
vous avez une caméra celle fille de 8
mégapixels et ouvre à f 2.0
côté logiciel c'est hyper efficace vous
avez votre petit tacle in home est pour
savoir où est-ce que vous en êtes vous
de votre appareil photo le mode portrait
la vision de nuit de la vidéo bien
évidemment et puis vous avez plein
d'autres modes la vidéo c'est pas
forcément sur ce smartphone que je veux
aller pour vraiment faire de très très
bonne vidéo
par contre l'appareil photo est
bon il vous montre ça dans quelques
instants le mode portrait ok vous allez
voir le résultat
d'ici quelques secondes là où plein
d'autres marques vont mettre plein plein
plein de capteur à l'arrière en vous
proposant un capteur principal un ultra
grand-angle et de la macro c'est souvent
ce qu'on va retrouver ici en 2020 en
tout cas dans les smartphone milieu de
gamme des vous monter en gamme vous
récupérez un téléobjectif en train de
rire ça c'est toi un petit peu là ici
google a fait le choix de mettre un seul
capteur et c'est ce qu'il disait avoir
notamment sur le google le pixel 3 et
puis que celle 3 a également ils en ont
rajouté un peu plus en pixels 4 mais là
ils sont vraiment dit ok on reste à
l'essentiel
on a un seul capteur on a un seul
objectif qui vous délivrera la meilleure
qualité alors ça va enlever un petit peu
en polyvalence ne va pas venir chercher
très très loin en ont joué dans l'image
sans quoi on va perdre en qualité je
vous montre le résultat dans quelques
instants mais par contre l'idée d'avoir
ça juste ça avec derrière la puissance
algorithmique de google puisque c'est
très clairement ce que nous propose de
ce smartphone est bien ça donne des
résultats qui sont vraiment mais
vraiment très très bon et à 349 euros
on est je pense ici dans une des
meilleures si ce n'est la meilleure
proposition en photo à ce tarif là sur
android voilà les fameuses photos faites
avec le pixel 4a photos en plein jeu
vous regardez c'est vraiment bien
maîtrisé on a bien tout le détail dans
les nuages même dans les zones d'ombré
il ya un très très très très très beau
travail que fait google là dessus le x 2
on peut faire des choses on vit un petit
peu joué dans l'image ne faut pas trop
s'amuser à venir nous mais on va
jusqu'au x 7 et a tout de suite c'est
pas terrible
il fallait plus impactés l'objectif
c'est normal photos de plats ça
fonctionne c'est bien ça donne un côté
très gourmand comment pourrais dire on a
presque envie de venir le croquer dedans
c'est vraiment pas mal du tout pour ce
regard quelques photos de nuit aussi là
dessus le pixel 4 ha est vraiment très
très bon niveau de la gestion des
lumières l'appareil
ici ça fonctionne on a vraiment bien le
ciel on a bien tout le détail avant même
les zones avec un peu plus la cena peu
plus sombre sur les côtés qui fonctionne
c'est vraiment vraiment vraiment pas mal
du tout c'est vraiment des gros points
forts de google là dessus c'est
l'algorithme est ce qu'ils sont capables
de vous sortir avec un seul objectif
toujours les photos de nuit ça
fonctionne très bien c'est parfait
petite photo avec mon gros pote nounours
prises à l'intérieur c'est pareil ça
fonctionne très bien photo nuit toujours
encore la photo de nuit là on est à
république
regardez là les différentes couleurs
comme elles sont bien restitués on voit
bien les arbres on a bien les lumières
derrière tout est bien c'est juste c'est
vraiment
mieux que dans la réalité la caméra
telle fille fonctionne aussi également
très bien colorimétrie ok ça me va c'est
bien c'est pas il sait c'est top et là
je vais vous montrer le mode portrait
comment il fonctionne
ça vous prend cette photo là et ensuite
ça vient appliquer le flou logiciel
c'est vraiment vraiment vraiment pas mal
c'est très drôle à novembre et comment
ça fonctionne alors il ya quelques
petites erreurs mais une fois de plus on
pas trop lui en vouloir sur un
smartphone à 2 349 euros ici la
justice'' ça m'a légèrement flouté un
peu l'oreille là il ya eu un petit peu
de mal ici là entre les doigts mais ça
passe on complexifie et c'est pas
anormal vu la puissance du processeur
derrière mais dans l'ensemble c'est
vraiment bien le travail au niveau des
cheveux et aussi pas mal bon sens et
quand on se rapproche à petits pas au
niveau du fond c'est plus délicat
ce qu'il faudrait pour avoir un résultat
à gré prochain c'est une caméra teuf ici
il n'y en a pas il n'y a pas de laser
mais malgré tout le résultat est
vraiment bien c'est aux smartphones qui
a du nfc qui n'a aucune tarification
d'étanchéité contre l'eau et la
poussière
une fois de plus sur un smartphone dans
cette gamme de prix c'est assez normal
et tous les autres font ça vous avez ici
un tiroir qui peut accepter une seule
nanosims mais vous pouvez avoir une
estime si votre opérateur vous le permet
laissez moi vous donner l'information
pour le das alors ici le das et le débit
d'absorption spécifique c'est
l'absorption aux ondes
vous avez un das tête qui 1,37 watts par
kilogramme d'astro de 1,39 watts par
kilogramme et hadass membres de troie ou
watts par kilogramme moi qui pour être
probablement négatif c'est un smartphone
qui n'est pas compatible 5 g dont vous
ne pouvez pas avoir de la 5g dessus vous
aurez laquelle deux sans problème et si
vous voulez vous de projeter dans
l'avenir les anges ne prend un
smartphone qui va durer deux ans trois
ans et je veux avoir de la 5g peut-être
l'année prochaine ou dans un an et demi
et bien sachez qu'avec celui là ça sera
pas possible c'est pas forcément tout de
suite très grave puisqu'on n'y en ait
pas eu de transition et qu'on manque
encore un peu de visibilité notamment en
france mais pour d'autres pays comme la
suisse qui propose de la 5g bien ça peut
être un petit peu embêtant et surtout
quand on voit qu'à ce tarif là à quelque
chose près des concurrents proposent des
smartphones avec de la 5g maintenant la
question c'est est-ce que la 5g part
importante pour vous on voit ce que vous
voulez vraiment un gros focus est une
très très belle qualité sur l'appareil
photo et vous pouvez vous passer de sa
jeep nous revoilà réflexion avoir à vous
de me dire ce que vous en pensez en bas
en commentaire alors pour moi ce
smartphone est fait pour vous si vous
cherchez déjà un smartphone sur android
ça serait le prérequis c'est la base si
vous voulez un smartphone compact qui se
tient
bien en main qui rentrent très
facilement dans une poche dans un sac à
main qui est très discret qu'on peut
emmener partout avec soi et qui va pas
débordés qui n'est pas extrêmement grave
si vous comparez avec un iphone os
pronax voit tout de suite qu'on est
vraiment un jeu blanc bas dans deux
mondes différents en terme de taille
ça c'est clair donc la question se pose
vraiment abattue sur le format sur la
prise en la qualité de l'écran pour le
multimédia est vraiment bonne la qualité
audio pour le multimédia est vraiment
excellente et le fait que vous ayez des
haut parleurs stéréo dans cette gamme de
prix ne soit plus assez bien et assez
rare nous avons plus le choix puisque
vous pouvez brancher un casque filaire
est une prise jack
très bien le fait d'avoir les codecs les
plus importants je dirais dans cette
gamme de prix est plus ça marche très
bien avec un bluetooth cinq points donc
on a vraiment une expérience qui est
cohérente on va pas avoir le smartphone
le plus performant mais vu ce qu'on a
essayé vu la copie les fluides il
marchera bien et vous ferez tourner
trois quarts des jeux de dupes les stars
sans problème alors allez pas me
chercher le jeu extrêmement gourmand a
poussé dans ses retranchements parce que
ça ne fonctionnera pas nécessairement
bien mais pour une fois de plus un usage
un peu standard et bien il sera passe
partout où il ira très bien la photo et
texte certes c'est vraiment le point
fort de ce smartphone le point un peu
négatif je pense que c'est l'autonomie
que vous n'avez pas peur de mettre un
petit coup de charges en journée ou en
tout cas il vous tiendra une journée
bon pourquoi pas moi j'aime beaucoup et
surtout je pense que vraiment ce
smartphone il faut y aller pour deux
points essentiels c'est la compacité le
petit écran ça c'est vraiment le plus
important
et puis la partie photo qui est vraiment
excellente à côté voilà mon point de vue
voilà mon avis aujourd'hui sur ce
smartphone en tout cas je l'approuvé je
trouve très bien maintenant vous
maintenant ce que vous en pensez en bas
en commentaire est ce que vous pourriez
vous laisser tenter par le google pixels
4 à est-ce qu'il vous intéresse alors il
est pas pour arriver à pas tarder à
arriver si vous allez sur le site de
google vous pouvez vous inscrire à une
lettre d'info qui vous enverra des infos
dès qu'il arrivera dès qu'ils seraient
disponibles en tout cas moi j'aime bien
je le trouve vraiment bien bien réussi
fait une très très belle proposition à
vous de me dire ce que vous en pensez en
bas en commentaire et puis vous restez
connectés parce que on se retrouve
extrêmement rapidement il ya plein de
choses qui arrivent plein de nouveautés
la tec ne s'arrête pas jamais et croyez
moi il ya plein de belles surprises qui
se profile
tu vois beaucoup d'amour pour le soin de
vous et à très vite en caoutchouc
[Musique]